the season finale of the Umbrella
Academy left us with a lot of burning
questions
we're going to unpack the first season
and look at some theories about where we
think season 2 is headed warning to
those of you who didn't binge this
series like we did spoilers ahead
nice to see nothing's changed that's it
that's all you have to say in season 1
of the Umbrella Academy we follow the
lives of the adopted children of
Reginald our grieves as adults these
siblings all have something in common
they were born on the same day from
remarkable spontaneous pregnancies all
over the globe they were believed to
possess extraordinary powers so
Hargreaves found and adopted seven of
the 43 babies who were born on that day
his motivation seemed to be to save the
world and while he seemed to care deeply
about me and times he didn't seem to
have any love at all for the children he
adopted this caused them to grow up
emotionally stunted and estranged from
one another all of the siblings seemed
to be unique in its special except for
Vanya who is played by Ellen Page Vanya
was always told by her father that she
was ordinary she was not allowed to
participate in the missions with her
brothers and sister she grew up feeling
invisible but that turned out to be
Hargreaves biggest trick of all even
bigger than a bogus four-year trip to
the moon and we're still feeling for
Luther on that one so the big reveal in
season 1 is that Vanya actually does
have powers and the Hargreaves kids have
to escape the apocalypse she causes by
jumping through time with five that
leaves us all dangling from a major
cliffhanger from the season finale there
are plenty of questions about what's in
store for season 2 we dug up a few
pretty interesting theories as to what's
in store for the Hargreaves children in
the next season here are a few ideas so
if you already binge the first season of
the Umbrella Academy you know that they
had discovered what was responsible for
the apocalypse that five jumped through
time to witness turns out Vanya is the
cause of the apocalypse apparently even
though she was made to believe that she
had no powers as a child Hargreaves was
lying to her all along he decided that
Baniyas powers were too powerful
so he made her believe she was ordinary
I'm afraid there's just nothing special
about you Benny gave her medication to
suppress her powers and had Alison use
her powers of persuasion to make Vanya
believe she was ordinary but during the
last episode of the season title the
white violin Vanya reveals just how
extraordinary she really is the only way
the Hargreaves kids can escape the
apocalypse she causes is by jumping to
some unknown time with five so where or
when did they go and what will change as
a result of their time jump one thing
that the show points to is the change in
their bodies when they're about to jump
through time at the end five warns them
that their appearances may change just
like him five knows all about that he
jumped through time when he was 13 years
old and bound up in the post-apocalyptic
future he couldn't jump back in time so
he was forced to live out his days in
the ash and rubble he was so lonely he
fell in love with a mannequin whose
upper half was untouched by the
destruction then five went on to join
the Commission and worked with them well
into his 50s but when he was finally
able to jump back to the point where our
story takes place he transformed from a
58 year old man to a 13 year old boy yet
he still retained all of his knowledge
and wisdom okay can we just pause and
appreciate Aiden Gallagher for a moment
the 15 year old actor had to play the
part of a 58 year old man who knew of an
impending apocalypse and could hold his
own with actors twice his age kudos
anyways since Phibes body referred it to
that of his 13 year old self it's likely
that the other siblings will become
their younger selves do with this time
gem that would be an interesting
direction it doesn't seem likely that
they would suddenly stop using the
powerhouse talent of the older actors
especially Ellen Page and Robert Sheehan
so will they jump to another time period
as their adult selves if so what will
happen to five will he become his 58
year old self again or will they somehow
justify him still being a teenager while
his siblings remain adults and what time
period are they going to jump to we know
that the goal of the Hargreaves clan is
to stop the apocalypse by helping Vanya
learn how to control her powers if she
learns how to control her powers she
won't cause the apocalypse later in the
future so it makes sense that the gang
would time jump back to earlier in their
childhoods now we don't have a lot
go on about the rules and specifics on
time travel so who knows how this is
going to work it's sleeping fans with a
lot of questions for example if they do
jump in time to a point in their own
timelines will they cause a paradox if
it doesn't completely disrupt the space
and time continuum does that mean we'll
be seeing double in season two will
there be two fives - losers - Vanya is
running around and what does this jump
mean for Ben we only see him as a spirit
who hangs out with Klaus for most of
season one from what we gather from his
scenes with Klaus he must have died as
an adult he comes to Klaus as an adult
so if they all go back in time will they
go to the time before Ben lost his life
and that begs the question that since
they're fixing the apocalypse could they
also fix Ben's death maybe they can rig
it so he lives and can move on with the
rest of his siblings so then maybe the
Ben who follows clouds around isn't his
ghost you know you don't have to do this
alone but the adult version of Ben who
survived as a result of his
time-traveling siblings that would
justify the fact that Ben is the only
one who can communicate with Klaus when
he's high he has to sober up in order to
communicate with any other members of
the deceased realm but is it even
possible to stop the apocalypse from
what we know from the Commission there
are some events that are just meant to
be it seems that this apocalypse is one
of those events when five starts working
for the Commission again he is strongly
discouraged from messing with the future
apocalyptic events yet he still tries to
negotiate a deal in which his siblings
will be saved so is the apocalypse set
in stone will it even be possible to
stop it season 2 will likely be headed
to the same endpoint as season 1 we all
know the apocalypse is coming the same
way we did in season 1 but we're viewing
it from a different angle this time and
will the Commission be trying to stop
the Hargreaves game even though five
blew up a lot of the Commission his boss
did say he was just another cog in a
wheel so it's likely there will be other
agents of the Commission hunting them
down they may need to enlist the help of
other extraordinary individuals do you
guys remember the beginning of season 1
they introduced this story by saying
that 43 babies were born on the same day
at the same time to unsuspecting mothers
all over the world who had not been
pregnant at all that morning they say
that Hargreaves was only able to adopt
seven of those children so what happened
to the other three
say did they see the heroic act of the
Umbrella Academy and decide to remain
anonymous if so it would be interesting
for these characters to emerge in season
2 maybe they had parents who wanted to
protect them and who kept their powers
hidden to avoid exploitation if that's
the case there's a chance that these
mystery kids are even more powerful than
the seven in the Umbrella Academy if
they are well-adjusted adults who came
from loving families
they are already far better equipped
than the Hargreaves children who seemed
to self-sabotage every chance they gave
she is a liability so what other powers
are out there and it must not be a
coincidence that these babies were all
miraculously born on the same day with
extraordinary gifts maybe they were born
with the sole purpose of stopping the
apocalypse even if one of them did cause
it to begin with so back to time-travel
when exactly are they going well one
theory is that they'll travel back to
the 1960s the reason we think this is
because the comic books that the show is
based on are set in an alternate
timeline in which JFK was never
assassinated
that's because v was supposed to
assassinate JFK but then he time jump to
the Umbrella Academy instead the
Umbrella Academy comic book series
Dallas centers around the assassination
of the late President so if they draw in
Dallas at all for the second season they
will most likely have to include the JFK
storyline but maybe they'll focus on the
upcoming comics Hotel oblivion instead
they may choose to focus on some
villains who have been banished to a
place called Hotel oblivion by the
Academy in the past there's an evil dude
named Perseus who is this rich CEO who
is after revenge because the Academy
imprisoned his father and there's also
dr. Terminal who is mentioned in episode
7 according to fans he is the closest
thing the Academy has to an arch-nemesis
the Academy may have to fight some old
demons and enemies in season two in the
first umbrella academy comic book series
apocalypse sweet Vanya storyline is a
lot different from the show in the comic
Vanya is invited to play the violin for
this Orchestra that wants to destroy the
world by playing this piece of music
called the apocalypse suite because she
harbors a lot of resentment toward her
family she decides to join the orchestra
then the conductor does all these insane
experiments on her brain washes her in
turns her into this super villain named
the white violin it started then five
shows up behind her and shoots her in
the head she winds up paralyzed and has
amnesia after that things went down a
little differently in the show in the
show it was Alison who fires a warning
shot near her head causing her to focus
her powers up toward the moon then she
blows a big chunk off the moon which
reigns down a bunch of meteors
and eventually that huge piece lands
wiping out the entire world so maybe
they'll sort of follow this storyline in
season 2 of the new show and get Vanya
amnesia that would make it easier for
her to be fixed by her siblings
minimising the chance that she'll blow
up the moon and subsequently the planet
we may also get to the bottom of
Reginald Hargreaves in season two we got
a glimpse into his backstory in season 1
but he's still a mystery in the comics
he's an alien with a magic monocle that
allows him to perceive the truth about
others showrunner Steve Blackman said
we're going to learn more about
Hargreaves later on in the series Steve
Blackman also confirmed that yes those
are spaceships shooting up from the
ground because of this it's pretty safe
to say that Hargreaves is probably still
going to be an alien on the show this
could explain his lack of human empathy
and compassion and what about Allison
and Luther will their relationship grow
in season two many are wondering if
their relationship is illegal since
their adopted siblings and they grew up
together it kind of toads the line
between appropriate and inappropriate
you look great they have always known
each other as brother and sister yep
they have this innocent sweet attraction
to one another while they were called
family by their father they weren't
really raised as a normal family after
all their mom is a robot they were
forced to do training drills and were
forbidden to talk during mealtimes so
their family was anything but normal
it only makes sense that they would
cling to each other in this abnormal
dysfunctional family we expected these
seeing a lot more of the relationship in
season 2 what do you think we can expect
in season 2 of the Umbrella Academy do
you think it will follow the comics or
fear into a different paths tell us in
the comments be sure to subscribe to the
things for our latest videos thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]